>> From the Library of Congress in Washington,
D.C.
[ Silence ]
[ Background Conversation ]
>> Betsy Peterson: It's so wonderful to see
so many people here on Friday night for a
fabulous lecture. That's so great [laughing].
Anyway, welcome. I'm Betsy Peterson. I am
the Director of the American Folklife Center
here at the Library of Congress. And I want
to welcome you to a very special edition of
our Benjamin Botkin Folklife Lecture Series.
Now, for those of you we don't know what that's
all about, the American Folklife Center was
founded in 1976 by Congress with a mandate
to preserve and present American folklife.
And we were placed here at the Library very
specifically. Congress chose the Library of
Congress as the site because the Library already
had an incredibly vast archive of traditional
music and culture. And so it seemed like the
best place to be. And it's an archive that
has been built for decades by the likes of
John and Alan Lomax and Benjamin Botkin. And,
actually, the archives plays a role and influences
the topic that Billy Bragg is going to be
talking about tonight. And we'll be finding
out more about that. The Benjamin Botkin Lecture
Series, which is named after one of those
distinguished folklorists, provides a platform
for professional -- I'm sorry -- professional
academic individuals, people from the public
sector, from the university, as well as colleagues
working independently in folklore at their
musicology, cultural heritage, and related
fields to share their findings in their ongoing
research. Now, that's great for the public.
I think that's great for you. And it's certainly
great for us here at the Center because these
lectures form an important part of our accusations
as well. And each one is recorded and becomes
a part of the permanent archive -- I mean
-- yes, part of the permanent archive here
at the Library so that future generations
can enjoy, listen, and study. So, that reminds
me of my last caveat for you all, which is
that this is a good time to say, if you have
a cell phone or a mobile device, please turn
it off or you will be memorialized in our
archive [laughter]. So this evening we have
a very special honor to present a Botkin lecture
who falls -- of -- a Botkin lecturer -- excuse
me -- who falls outside of the usual categories
of academic or public sector research. And
so to introduce Billy Bragg and his work,
please welcome our own Steve Winick. Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephen Winick: Thank you. As Betsy mentioned,
I'm Steve Winick. I'm the Editor here at the
American Folklife Center at the Library of
Congress. And I should say that this event
is also cosponsored by the Folklore Society
of Greater Washington so we want to thank
FSGD for cosponsoring this with is. And I
should also say that I'm pretty thrilled to
have such a distinguished speaker. When I
was a teenager, I confess, that I was a big
Billy Bragg fan. And he's one of the first
artists whose work I got as it came out as
opposed to years after it came out because
I was just old enough in the 1980s to have
money and to have friends who were cool. And
that's a big theme in Billy's book as well,
the importance of teenagers in the music scene.
So, like many people, my musical tastes kind
of changed over the years and I ended up involved
in traditional folk music and working here
in a folklore archive, The American Folklife
Center archive here at the Library of Congress.
And last year it came to my attention that
Billy Bragg had recorded an album called Shine
A Light, which includes several songs that
are first known from recordings in our archive.
So I set about trying to get Billy here for
our program. And I got as far as discussing
in seriously when the album's promoter or
the publicist, but he just didn't have time
on his last trip to D.C. to come here. Now,
what I didn't know at that time was that Shine
A Light came about because of his research
for a book about skiffle. And I knew something
about skiffle from years as a music journalist
and also because, working here, many of our
recordings were important to the skiffle craze.
So here's where the story gets cool and a
little bit weird. Back at the end of 2016,
Billy was getting the book ready for release
and he realizes that maybe this is a better
opportunity to come to the Library of Congress.
Right? So that's what happens then. And he
vaguely must have remembered that some dude
at the Library of Congress had been trying
to get him here before, but he's not working
with that album publicist anymore, so how
to find the dude at the Library of Congress?
And that's when I get a message from my high
school girlfriend, Jenny Lewis of Toronto,
who says, "Send me your contact info at work.
Billy Bragg wants to meet with you."
[ Laughter ]
So I'm not making this up. Billy's good friend,
Avi Lewis, is the brother of my high school
sweetheart and that's how he found me. And
this would just be a funny story, except that
I think it demonstrates Billy's tenacity as
a researcher and his canny use of social networks
and social media, all of which contributed
to this book that he'll tell you about. So,
without further ado, I will say that Billy
Bragg is a singer, songwriter, activist, and
author. He's known for beautiful love songs,
for powerful political songs, and for standing
up for what's right. In the folk world, he's
also well-known for being one of the people
who Nora Guthrie and the Guthrie family specifically
asked to write music for many of Woody Guthrie's
unsung lyrics resulting in the Mermaid Avenue
sessions. And all of these activities have
deep connections to our archive and the Library
of Congress. So, from now on, he will also
be known as the author of an important book
on skiffle called "Roots, Radicals, and Rockers:
How Skiffle Changed the World." So, without
another word from me, please welcome our very
special speaker, Billy Bragg.
[ Applause ]
>> Billy Bragg: Thank you very much.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
Thank you very much, everybody. I'd like to
thank the American Folklife Center for inviting
me here and Steve's girlfriend for making
it happen.
[ Laughter ]
Yes. I was kind of telling everybody about
the book -- the book was coming because I
thought it was a book that may be interesting
to people in North America, particularly here
in the United States where the bands of the
British Invasion are still so important to
you. We were actually touring at the time
when -- just last year with the Shine A Light
record -- we were touring around the time
Eight Days A Week was released, the Beatles
movie, and it was making such a big splash.
I was thinking to myself, "I hope I can find
some way to connect these guys with the story
I'm trying to tell," because it's a crucial
part of that British Invasion story. And,
of course, it's inspired by music that's -- some
of which was recorded on behalf of the Library
of Congress in the 1930s and in the 1940s.
So let's start with -- let's start with the
word, "skiffle." Skiffle is one of those words
which you have to be very careful. It has
a different meaning in the United States of
America than it has in the UK. So a word like,
"Pants."
[ Laughter ]
Or "fag."
Or, "Socialism," actually for that matter
now I think about it.
[ Laughter ]
Which is why [inaudible], "football," at the
top of that list of words that you have to
be very careful how you use it when you come
to this country because you get a lot of quizzical
look. The word, "skiffle," originates in African
American slang in the 1920s. The story that
comes to us in the UK says it originates on
the south side of Chicago, but I'm sure it's
much wider than that. A skiffle was a name
that African Americans gave to what we might
call a rent party where they would organize
some -- some food, cook some down home food
often from the place where they originated
in the South. They would brew up some hooch,
get a boogie woogie piano player to come around
and charge money at the door to raise some
money. The word doesn't really have a strong
musical connotation in the United States of
America. It was used by Paramount Records
in the '20s who made an album called, "Down
Home," -- sorry -- a single called, "Down
Home Skiffle," which was kind of like a -- a
record that featured all their artists. It
was like a sampler for the label. They had
half a dozen artists on each side playing
a couple of tunes and the concept of the thing
was they were at a down home skiffle. And
it ends with a knock at the door [knocking]
and the narrator says it's the police and
they've come to break up the down home skiffle.
So that's -- that's the kind of early-ish
use, but it's not a word that's picked up
by African American musicians or anybody else
for that matter until 1947 when a guy named
Dan Burley records an album of songs that
he played as a young man in Chicago on the
South Side in the 1920s. Dan Burley is a kind
of Renaissance figure in African American
culture in the 1940s. He's a cofounder of
Ebony Magazine. He hangs out with a lot of
jazz greats, Ellington, and also writes a
very popular dictionary of African American
hip slang. And during -- in the context of
the Trad Jazz Revival, someone says to him,
"Why don't you make an album of those great
barrelhouse piano tunes that you made in the
1920s that you sang [inaudible]?" So he gets
together with Sticks and Brownie McGhee and
they record an album called "South Side Shake"
of predominately barrelhouse piano tunes.
And the album is credited to Dan Burley and
his Skiffle Boys. Now, in this context, he's
talking about, we might say Dan Burley and
his party boys. In my country, we would call
it Dan Burley and his it" knees-up" boys.
That's what we'd call it. It's a slang word
for "party" in England, "A good old knees-up."
So, yeah. In this context, "skiffle," is still
referring to an event. Now, the Trad Jazz
Revival kind of kicks off in the late 1930s
where jazz fans, predominantly, begin to seek
out the earliest recordings by -- particularly
by New Orleans jazz bands because they believed
that modern jazz -- not modern jazz, but contemporary
jazz -- I think what we would not refer to
as swing, has become too commercial, too big-time,
too white break, and the jazz has lost its
essence. And they begin to try to seek the
earliest records and eventually they kind
of come to an idea that New Orleans jazz is
the only true, pure jazz. And what's special
about New Orleans jazz is it has no soloists.
The players play constantly all the time in
and out of the rhythm and around one another.
So Louis Armstrong, I know he's from New Orleans,
once he goes to Chicago and starts playing
solos, he's out, baby. He's out. They draw
a line -- they draw a line in the sand just
north of Lake Pontchartrain [laughing]. And
anyone who crosses this line has gone over
to the dark side. And in that, what they were
trying to do, those fans -- and then, in my
country, which it was very popular after the
war -- there wasn't a trad jazz band in Britain
until 1943 when a guy named George Webb, who
worked in a machine gun factory, got together
with a bunch of workmates to play -- or tried
to play trad jazz. They didn't have a bass.
They had a tuba. They couldn't find a bass,
so they had a tuba.
[ Laughter ]
But they were basically trying to get a handle
on this music that really moved them. They
didn't know where it was from. They couldn't
-- they couldn't put their finger on why it
moved them so they were trying to play it.
So a trad jazz movement grew up and the impulse
-- the trad jazz impulse is not something
unfamiliar in popular music. In many ways,
the trad jazz aficionados, in trying to go
back to basics to renew music, were following
the same impulse of the Ramones in your country
and Dr. Feelgood in my country in the mid-1970s
when appalled by the commerciality of guitar
rock. They sought to go back to the earliest
sort of rock-'n'-roll, the absolute most basic
rock-'n'-roll, that kind of idea that when
music becomes stale, the way forward is sometimes
to be found in the very back of the corner
of the record store, in the back of the racks
-- if you can find a record store -- in the
back of the racks. It's quite a potent idea.
And, unfortunately for the guys who want to
play trad jazz in my countries in the late
'40s and the early '50s, there's a musicians
union ban on American bands touring in Great
Britain. It's a reciprocal ban in response
to the American Federation of Musicians stipulating
in 1935 that British band leaders could only
tour in the United States of America if they
used American musicians and took out American
citizenship. It's the worst kind of protectionism
and as many of you all know I'm a staunch
supporter of organized labor. It's totally
embarrassing and that it should happen in
music as well is -- it's -- but I cover it
extensively in the book -- because it's absolutely
unbelievable. This band -- the Ministry of
Labor in British, the Musicians Union, asked
the Ministry of Labor to institute a reciprocal
ban. So between 1935 and 1955 no American
band toured the UK and no British artist band
toured the United States of America. That's
a long time. Imagine if it had been 1965 to
1985.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, just think about that. No Beatles.
No Jimi Hendrix. No Judas. I mean, it's an
incredible long time. And these were the days
when the only way to find out how to play
a musical star was to watch, to see, to sit
on the edge of the stage and watch someone
play, and listen to their technique. That
was the way people learned how to play, but,
sadly, for the British trad guys, the only
way they had to learn was to listen to these
very early recordings, these precious earlier
recordings that they believed were the only
real true jazz. Now, due to the primitive
nature of recording in the 1920s, the musicians
on those records really had to blow hard to
get onto the record. They blew like Billy
O. So the British jazz guys figured that was
all part and parcel have it so they blew the
hell out of their instruments. They really
went for it. Because, I mean, jazz, you it,
trad jazz has that pep thing. Maybe it was
one of the things that first attracted people
to it, that zip and pep. But, as a result
of not having much technique, the British
jazz guys, after 30 minutes, their lips were
so numb, they couldn't play anymore.
[ Laughter ]
So they were in a bit of a quandary. So what
they did was they put down their brass instruments
and they picked up acoustic guitar, washboard,
and used the double bass from the jazz band
and they performed what broadly you would
refer to as Lead Belly's repertoire. And I
say Lead Belly because -- I'm not sure if
I'm allowed to say this this building, but
he is the greatest folk singer that America
ever produced, not only as a performer, as
an interpreter, as a writer, as a popularizer.
You know, Lead Belly was to Woody what Woody
was to Bob. You know, Woody used to kind of
sit around Lead Belly's house on 14th Street,
sit in the corner and watch him play and listen
to him talk. The man was physically a giant,
but also culturally, in your country and my
country, he was a giant. So the reason they
played Lead Belly's repertoire was because
there was an element of education and what
they were trying to do. In my country in the
1950s, you could learn about jazz by going
to something called a record recital because
his music wasn't really played on the BBC.
It was the only radio station at the time.
You would go to somewhere like Wigmore Hall
in London, which holds 1,200 people, and they
would sell out something called a record recital,
which is basically a jazz critic playing his
jazz collection on a wind up foghorn record
player and talking about the context in which
these records are playing, who is playing,
what, you know -- what the connections between
this and other artists are. This was kind
of really the only way to find out about jazz.
And so, in that context, playing these Lead
Belly songs, the trad jazzers believed that
they were educating their audience in where
jazz came from. They believed that jazz had
evolved from the blues partly because -- they
were mistaken in this -- the blues -- the
twelve-form blues -- twelve-bar blues, we
know, postdates New Orleans jazz. But I think
they were misled by the fact that the trad
jazzers used the term, "blues," on their records
when they actually meant a kind of loose playing,
like a jam. A blues would be a song that,
you know, everyone was adding their own bit
to. So there was an easy mistake to make.
So, anyway, they began performing these Lead
Belly songs and the guy who was the key proponent
of this was a fellow called Ken Collyer and
Ken Collyer was absolutely obsessed with New
Orleans jazz. He was a trumpet player and
one of the giants of the revival was a guy
named Bunk Johnson. Bunk Johnson was a guy
who claimed to have played with Buddy Bolden
back in New Orleans. Buddy Bolden, allegedly
the guy who invented New Orleans jazz. Again,
I know there's probably half a dozen of you
who are going to argue about that later, but
I'm just passing on what's taken for fact
in my country. Bunk Johnson disappeared in
the 1920s. He was rediscovered in the '40s
and made a couple of recordings with a band
that included George Lewis on clarinet. George
Lewis being one of the few New Orleans clarinet
players who hadn't traded up to be a saxophone
player when swing came along. And although
Bunk was dead, George Lewis and the rest of
the Johnson band was still playing in New
Orleans. So they were playing in little whole-in-the-wall
dives to people of a similar age to them,
which is in the late 60s, early 70s. They
weren't playing to young African Americans.
They tended to be much more interested in
the modern version of jazz, which, interestingly,
modern jazz, bebop, had come from that same
impulse to get away from the commerciality
of swing. It's unfortunate that the trads
and the moderns ended up at war with one another,
but it was a similar impulse. The beboppers
were just trying to make the future happen
rather than going back to the past. But George
Lewis was still playing in New Orleans. And
Ken Colyer knew this and he finally realized
that the only way he would really learn to
play New Orleans jazz was to get to New Orleans.
Now, in 1950s Britain -- early 1950s Britain,
this is a mountain to climb. It's a real mountain
to climb. The British government has currency
restrictions which only allow you to take
10 pound per person out of the country because
they're afraid of a run on the pound. And
the fair across the Atlantic to get into the
United States of America is not so straightforward
for him. So he comes up with a brilliant plan.
He joins the Merchant Marine.
[ Laughter ]
Now, the Merchant Marine in my country works
on a taxing rank principle. You go down, they
give you a chit with the name of a ship, you
go to the ship, you give it to them, you have
to join the ship, they have to take you. So
his first trip he goes to Australia.
[ Laughter ]
His second trip he goes to the Gulf of Arabia.
And the third trip he goes around the Cape
of Good Hope. So after 18 months at sea, he's
sitting back in the office waiting for another
chit when the guy next to him looks at his
chit he's just been given and says, "Dammit,
Mobile, Alabama."
[ Laughter ]
To which Ken Colyer says, "I'll swap you."
So they trade and Colyer gets to go to Mobile,
Alabama on a ship running up and down to the
Orinoco Cove where oil is discovered off of
the coast of Venezuela. And after a couple
of trips as the ship's cook, he gets to New
Orleans, he jumps ship, he leaves the ship,
and he gets a month long visa and rides the
rails into New Orleans where he happens to
-- there's a guy named Doc Souchong [assumed
spelling] who's a jazz critic and also played
in string bands in the 1910, 1911 who's a
critic whose name he knows. In in those days
British libraries had phone book -- well,
the Westminster library -- just the Westminster
library, had phone books for American cities.
And so before he's left, he's gone and found
Doc Souchong's phone number under MDs because
he's a real doctor. That's how he found him.
He tried finding George Lewis, but there were
too many George Lewis's in the phone book.
So he found Doc Souchong and Doc Souchong
takes him to meet George Lewis and the band.
He sees George Lewis and the band and, of
course, he's bought his trumpet. And, of course,
he knows their entire set. He knows their
repertoire inside out. These guys are so made
up, this young guy that's come here all the
way from England. They're so pleased that
someone's interested, someone young is interested
in their music. So they say to him, "Why don't
you sit up and play with us?" So Colyer, not
only has he gone to the mountain top, not
only has he climbed Olympus, but now he's
sitting in with the Gods. I mean, this is
just incredible. So he writes home to his
brother who's a huge -- works in a Dobell's
jazz shop in London, he's an expert on traditional
jazz, he's writing home to his brother, Bill.
Brother Bill's passing the letters onto the
Melody Maker who are printing them. So people
are reading -- this is unbelievable. Colyer's
like in New Orleans. It's like he's gone to
the moon. You know? It's like impossible.
Everyone's like amazed by this.
[ Laughter ]
But not everyone's amazed. Some people are
very angry. Some people don't think a white
boy should sit down and play with black musicians.
This is around the time that your government
was getting very suspicious of any subversive
activity. And what Ken Colyer was doing was
subversive. And the proof of that is that
when he went to renew his month visa, he was
arrested. Now, he was a day late on his visa.
His visa was due for renewal on December the
25th. So you can imagine they might say, "Well,
fair enough, son. You couldn't get here on
Christmas Day. We'll renew it." And even if
they didn't say that, the usual way to deal
with someone who's violated their -- the -- thing
to get them in the country, is to put them
in a hostile until they can be deported. Ken
Colyer is put in jail with no bail. He's kept
there for 38 days. It's absolutely clear.
And whenever they ask him why he's come to
New Orleans, he says, "I've come to New Orleans
to play with those guys." And they keep him
in jail all that time. It's clear that, you
know, they saw him as someone who was challenging
the Jim Crow law in New Orleans. And everybody
in the jazz community, Doc Souchong and those
people that he's been staying with are trying
to get him out of jail. They're appalled.
They're absolutely appalled. Ken -- Ken's
really pleased because now he's the only person
in Britain who will be able to sing Penitentiary
Blues with any credibility.
[ Laughter ]
Because he's still writing to his brother
and this is still appearing on the pages of
the Melody Maker. He's like -- not only has
he played with Bunk Johnson's band, he's now
in jail in Louisiana like Lead Belly himself.
I mean, how great is this! So after 38 days,
they resolve the -- he was -- he has the problem
of how he gets home resolved for him when
he's deported on the SS United States of America,
which, at the time, has the blue ribbon for
landing crossings. So, having come over as
the second cook on an oil boat, he kind of
goes back in some style and he's met at the
boat train by his brother and a ready-made
band. He comes back to London like the Trad
Jazz Moses, down from the mountain to tell
it as it is. You know? And his brother has
pulled together a band led by Chris Barber
on trombone, has Monty Sunshine on clarinet,
Ron Bowden on drums, and includes Lonnie Donegan
on banjo. And they become the Ken Colyer Jazz
Men. And they instigate this breakdown session
as an integral part of what they do. But one
day they're doing a radio program for the
BBC and the rather observant BBC producer
notices that -- they decide to do some skiffle
songs. So they put down their brass instruments.
They reconfigure. Lonnie Donegan comes to
the mic. They have to set up the vocal mic.
Lonnie Donegan comes to the mic to sing. Colyer's
playing guitar. Barber plays the bass. Bill
Colyer plays a bit of washboard. And the producer
says, "Well, hang on a minute. Hang on a minute.
This is not the Ken Colyer Jaz Men and they're
definitely not playing jazz." So he says to
the band's manager, "Well, what is this? What
is this music and who are -- you know -- who
is this band?" So Bill Colyer, his brother
-- Ken's brother -- says, "This is the Ken
Colyer Skiffle Group." And in that moment
he takes the meaning of the word, "Skiffle,"
and changes it completely to mean a sub-genre
of American roots music indigenous to the
United Kingdom.
[ Laughter ]
It can happen.
It goes from being an event, a -- a house
party -- to actually being a type of music
played -- played in the UK. Why did he choose
the term, "Skiffle?" Obviously, he knows Dan
Burley and his skiffle boys record. It was
very popular in the UK. The real reason I
suspect is because if Bill Colyer tried to
tell the BBC that he and his brother were
playing the blues, they would have been laughed
out the broadcasting house. All of the credibility
that Ken got by going to New Orleans would
have gone down the tubes because everybody
knew in 1953 Great Britain that the blues
could only be played by old African American
guys. Everyone knew that. So, instead, in
order to get to this music and to have the
-- the validity to be able to play this music,
they had to find a kind of -- another way.
And it's really important that they found
a term that did have some roots in African
American culture. It's really, really important
to them. I mean, there's a few other words
he could have chose. He could have chose "jug
band." There were some elements of jug band
in skiffle. He could have chosen "spasm band"
because the spasm bands made their own instruments.
But he chose skiffle -- he chose skiffle and
I like to think he chose skiffle because it
has the kind of automatic sound of a washboard
being scraped and cheap Czechoslovakian guitars
being played not in tune. So that was -- that
was how skiffle got its name in the UK. Now,
Ken Colyer was a -- you might have seen some
photo -- did -- you ran the photographs earlier.
You might have seen it was the guy wearing
the jacket, it had the word "Smile" on it
and had the biggest frown you've ever seen.
Ken -- Ken -- he's in the book. Ken was one
of those guys who frowned upon any modernity
music. When the band used to go outside the
London clubs and play to audiences that wanted
something familiar to dance to, Ken frowned
on that and nobody could frown like Ken Colyer.
He could have frowned for England if we had
had a frowning team. So --
[ Laughter ]
One of the things he really didn't like was
Lonnie Donegan. Lonnie Donegan was a sort
of -- he was already a star in his own mind
and him coming from the back of the band stand
where he played in the rhythm section with
the -- the drums and the bass to the front
of the stage, he just owned the place. He
owned the place! And, unfortunately, Ken Colyer
had a bit of a chip on his shoulder about
this. So he went to Chris Barber and he said,
"I'm going to sack Donegan. I can't stand
him." And -- and, years later [laughing],
Chris Barber told me, "You see, that's no
grounds for sacking Lonnie Donegan. Nobody
could stand him."
[ Laughter ]
So -- but Barber, being the noble soul that
he is, he said to Colyer, "I'm sorry, Ken,
this is a collective. This band is a collective
and we have to make collective decisions."
So they had a band meeting, took a vote, and
they sacked Ken Colyer.
[ Laughter ]
And Ken Colyer [laughing] -- Ken Colyer went
off and formed his jazz band with a new bunch
of guys and Chris Barber formed his own jazz
band, got a new trumpet player. And in 1954
they made rival records for Decca. Both featured
skiffle songs -- a couple of skiffle songs.
Colyer's band lacked that cutting everything.
Colyer himself saying he was not a great -- he
wasn't a great singer. He was a great trumpet
player. He wasn't a great singer. Alexis Korner
was in his skiffle band. He played the mandolin
in Ken Colyer's skiffle band. Alexis Korner
who went on to found the British R&B boom
by running a club from which the Rolling Stones
and the Yardbirds and many of those bands
emerged, the [inaudible] club in the early
'60s. But Barber -- Barber was trying to push
the envelope as much as he could with his
own little jazz band. And, on the 13th of
July, 1954, he was booked to record an album
of New Orleans jazz called New Orleans Joys
for the Decca label. And it soon became clear
that they didn't have enough new material
to live up to Chris Barber's vision. And the
producer, Hugh Mendel was aghast at this because
he'd made Decca put up 30 pounds to -- which
is not a lot with the exchange rate the way
it is at the moment I'll tell ya -- the session
was going to crash when Donegan said, "Well,
why don't we record a couple of skiffle songs?"
because they needed eight tracks and they
only had six. So the producer says, "I don't
care what you do. I just need -- [inaudible]
with enough tracks." So Barber picked up the
double bass. Donegan got on the guitar and
the telephoned Beryl Bryden who was Britain's
premiere washboard player. And she came down
with a musical washboard. And in short time
they recorded "Rock Island Line", Lead Belly's
"Rock Island Line", and John Henry. And the
album was released in 1955 and got some very,
very nice reviews in the context of New Orleans
jazz. And that was kind of it for a while.
The jazz band carried on playing and they
carried on doing their skiffle breakdowns
and -- and towards the end of 1955 someone
at Decca Records decides to release "Rock
Island Line" as a single. It's not absolutely
clear why that is, but "Rock Island Line"
is released as a single in December -- November
1955. And it appears in the charts -- the
first chart of 1956. Lonnie Donegan, "Rock
Island Line" appears in the charts. And I
think in order to -- you've probably heard
all these songs in the warmup music, but I
think in the context of what we're doing now,
I think we should have a listen to "Rock Island
Line". Gus, if you could play track five,
please, that would be great.
[ Music ]
There he
was gone. Lonnie Donegan, "Rock Island Line"
recorded in July 13th, 1954. Some context.
Just one month before Lonnie Donegan recorded
that song, the rationing of food ended in
Britain. It'd begun in 1940 during the war
and continued after the war. Rationing of
clothing, rationing of petrol, rationing of
food. What that meant was that if a child
was born in 1940, let's call him John Lennon,
he would have to wait until he was 14 years
old before he could go into a sweet shop and
buy what he wanted. Sweets were on the ration.
Cakes were on the ration. Childhood was on
the ration. And what happens in 1954, '55
is that first generation of war babies leaves
school and they find work pretty easily. There's
a lot of semi-skilled labor work there particularly
with young women going to work in factories.
And they're earning good money, sometimes
more than their parents. And they only have
one expense, which is giving some housekeeping
to their mums. So what happens in '54, '55
is sales of cosmetics, of records, of clothing
start to rocket. And for the first time a
group of consumers and a cultural group become
visible in the UK and that group are teenagers.
Now, there were teenagers, of course, between
the war, but they tended to be -- the ones
that were visible to us -- tended to be middle
class and upper class teenagers, the flappers,
who were known to the -- to papers. There
was no teen culture between the wars. What
happens in '54, '55 is this cohort of working
class -- and it is exclusively working class
kids because the middle class and upper class
kids went to university and tended to go into
professions that deferred earning until adulthood
such as medicine and the law. So these kids,
they have never been visible before. The music
that's been made available for them has been
novelty songs for children, How Much Is That
Doggie in the Window. And the BBC just doesn't
really sort of cater for that kind of demographic.
They don't -- they don't really see them.
And the context of what was happening -- Gus,
if you could just play track 21, if you wouldn't
mind. This is a song that was number one when
"Rock Island Line" was recorded.
[ Music ]
Don't worry. We won't have to hear all of
it. Just to give you a flavor.
[ Music ]
That'll do, Gus. Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Culture -- culture as such was mediated by
the BBC. The BBC was the only broadcaster
and the only TV station. There was no commercial
broadcasting, no commercial TV station until
1955. You could hear rock-'n'-roll if you
listened to Luxemburg, Radio Luxemburg, which
was coming out of Europe, or the American
Forces Network, which was audible if you lived
near an American base. But really the BBC
had a dead hand on culture. So, in 1955, when
on the back of the popularity of the movie
Blackboard Jungle, Rock Around the Clock gets
into the charts. The BBC doesn't really play
it. There's a program called Family Favorites,
which is a request program and there's a chance,
if you listen to that, enough people might
have requested Rock Around the Clock that
they might play it and you might hear it.
So what happens is when "Rock Island Line"
comes out, a new -- a new idea comes forward,
you know, because obviously having heard Rock
Around the Clock and also in 1955 there's
a number of what we refer to in my country,
what they referred to at the time, is hillbilly
songs, get into the charts. This will be Slim
Whitman. It will be Tennessee Ernie Ford.
And these are kind of coming in on the back
of the arrival of commercial telly and their
propensity to buy cowboy series from the United
States of America and broadcast them. And
so this -- kind of these figures are emerging
in our culture playing guitars because the
guitar is not really an integral part of British
culture in the first half of the 20th century.
There are some guitars played in the musical,
but really if you heard or saw a guitar on
the telly or on the radio, it was often in
the context of an outsider character. It would
be a singing cowboy, a bluesman, or a calypsonian,
calypso was the identifying culture of the
first wave of migration to our country beginning
in 1948 from the Caribbean. And although calypso
comes from Trinidad, it kind of became the
identifying culture of the West Indian migration
when the West Indies defeated England in a
cricket match for the first time in 1950 and
a couple of calypso songs got into the charts.
So really it was an outsider's instrument,
the guitar. And Donegan is -- doesn't look
like a British singer. You know, all of our
singers -- one of our singers had a hit just
before Donegan put out with the theme title
from the movie, The Man from Laramie. It was
a cover of a Jimmy Stewart song. But even
on the leave of that record, the singer was
wearing a dinner jacket and a bowtie. That's
the image. And there's Donegan, doesn't even
have a normal tie on and he's kind of singing
that song, he's lashing at that song like
it's -- you know, he's on a runaway train.
It's kind of getting away from him. And the
most amazing thing in it, it transpires that
he was born in Glasgow and he's lived in London
most of his life. So when he goes on tour
in 1956 -- in late 1956 -- he's bringing a
message that's probably the most revolutionary
that British youth were ever -- ever learned
and that is, a, you don't have to be a trained
musician to make music, and b, you don't have
to be an American to sing American songs.
And this is -- this is a startling experience
for a lot of young people. Van Morrison is
12 years old when he hears Donegan singing
"Rock Island Line". He's familiar with Lead
Belly -- Lead Belly's version -- because his
father collects blues and jazz records from
an importer, Atlantic Records, in Belfast.
But his own aspirations to play music focused
on Irish folk music. He can imagine himself
playing that. It could never have imagined
himself singing "Rock Island Line" because
it's -- it's a blues song. He hears Donegan
and he's -- you know, he's awake. He suddenly
recognizes that he can sing these songs as
well. If Donegan can sing them, so can he.
So he forms a band. He forms his own little
skiffle band. And it's, you know, startling
to think that someone as young as 12 could
be moved by that. But George Harrison was
13 when he first saw Donegan in Liverpool
at the Empire in November, 1956. He went every
night to see Donegan. Donegan was there for
a week. It's a variety circuit. It's the only
circuit there was and it's like vaudeville
circuit and they played two shows five nights
a week. George Harrison went every night.
He was 13. Paul McCartney was 14. He went
one night and he came home and he told his
dad he didn't want to play trumpet anymore,
he wanted to play guitar. And it's not recorded
whether John Lennon went, but it's significant
that within two weeks of Donegan playing in
Liverpool, Lennon had formed his own skiffle
band, The Quarrymen. And it's the age of these
kids that is really so significant because
it's something that never happened again in
our culture, such a level. You know, skiffle
was not like a normal scene of music, you
know, professional musicians deciding to play
some music. It's much more akin to the fidget
spinners craze, which is currently --
[ Laughter ]
I'm afraid it is. It's a complete -- skiffle
was a playground craze. It was a playground
craze. Every sentient schoolboy in the UK
learned to play the three chords necessary
to play all of Donegan's repertoire. You know,
it was -- they were basically finding old
guitars that were knocking around. They were
importing them from -- from Czechoslovakia.
Sales of acoustic guitars in Britain in three
years went from 5,000 a year to 250,000 a
year. It's like the Cabbage Patch dolls. You
know this? It is! There are stories in the
book of, you know, guys saying, "You know,
I had a man in here the other day waving around
a 10 pound note asking for a guitar and I
couldn't find one. I couldn't get one for
him." You know, it's not just a small group
of people playing music that spreads. This
is like -- this is like absolute wildfire.
Why would it spread so quickly? What could
possibly be driving something like that? My
sense of is it's to do with the BBC and Rock
Around the Clock. When the BBC refused to
play Rock Around the Clock, those kids said,
"You're going to ration rock-'n'-roll? You're
going to ration bloody rock-'n'-roll? You
know what you can do with that, mate?" And
they went out and made their own music. They
went out and made their own sound. They got
together. They borrowed their mom's washboards.
They made a thing called a tea chest bass.
Now, a tea chest bass -- a tea chest is a
kind of meter high box, meter by a meter,
by a meter square box that we used to import
tea leaves into the UK with. There was -- everyone
had one in their house because they were used
for storage boxes. So everybody had one. To
open them, they literally saw -- there's metal
rims around all the edges to make it sturdy.
And they just saw the top -- saw a hole in
the top and take the top out in one piece.
But if you then turn the box upside down and
add a broom pole to the side and draw a piece
of twine to the center of what was the base
that's now the top of the tea chest, you can
kind of get a duhn-duhn-duhn kind of sound.
If you look -- the guy lying on his back on
the right there, you can just see the twine
of the -- of the tea chest bass. And that
flat line under his hand, that's the broom
pole. And the reason he's lying on his back
is because that's what Bill Haley's bass player
did. He'd lay on his back and lay on top of
his instrument and so they -- they went out
and learned to -- the three chords necessary
to play Donegan's repertoire. And Donegan
continued to have hits and other artists had
hits. But really -- really what it -- it was
this kind of underground things. It was these
kind of kids. You know? And what's significant
I think and different from the experience
here in the United States of America is I
can't think of a musical genre that has had
the majority of its performers under the age
of 18. I don't think that happened here. Yes,
there were people playing folk music here.
Of course there were. There were people playing
the blues here. But it wasn't -- it wasn't
absolute, you know, sub-teen grassroots and
so huge as it was in my country. Donegan has
a hit in the United States of America in the
summer of 1956, "Rock Island Line". It gets
to number eight in the Billboard Charts. It
appears on the Ed Sullivan show and does a
skit with Ronald Reagan.
[ Laughter ]
And he tours around the country. He ends up
on a kind of rock-'n'-roll tour -- a package
tour -- headlined by Chuck Berry. But he has
a bit of a problem -- a ban on musicians traveling
that ends in 1955 finally comes to an end,
which allows him to travel. But he's -- he's
like me, Lonnie Donegan. He's not really musical.
He doesn't write notation. You know? He's
kind of that -- so he's got no notation and
so he's doing like six shows a day starting
at 11 O'clock in the morning in cinemas playing
with a pit orchestra that doesn't really know
what he's talking about. When they get to
Detroit, one of the other bands on the -- on
the bill, the Rock-'n'-Roll Trio, that's Johnny
Burnette and Dorsey Burnette and Burlison,
probably the greatest rockabilly band outside
of Elvis, Scotty, and Bill. They're also playing.
And Johnny Burnette says, "Listen, man, why
don't you let us accompany with you those
songs? We -- you know, we can play that stuff.
Why don't you let us play rather than these
old guys?" And Donegan being Donegan says,
"Oh, I don't know if I can afford that." Johnny
Burnette says, "It's not about money, man.
It's about music." So for a few weeks on the
rest of that tour in Detroit and around the
Midwest, skiffle meets rockabilly as an equal
and recognizes that they are coming from the
same kind of place. Unfortunately, there's
no recordings of this. It's a real shame.
But I think if you're looking for something
in the United States of America that would
be similar in its shape and duration, it would
be rockabilly. Rockabilly is superseded by
rock-'n'-roll, Elvis at RCI and all that kind
of stuff in the same way that skiffle is superseded
by British Elvis impersonation -- impersonators
by the middle of 1958. But here's a really
interesting fact. Donegan records "Rock Island
Line" 30th of July, 1954, speeds up an old
blues song and saves a recording section that's
gone absolutely nowhere. Just a week before
in Memphis, Tennessee, Sam Phillips at Sun
Records is trying to coax an Ernest Tubb song
out of a rather recalcitrant truck driver
and it's not really going anywhere. So he
says, "Look. Just take a break." And this
kid who's a bit sort of nervous, he picks
up an acoustic guitar and he starts playing
a goofy version of a song called "That's All
Right Momma." And the bass player, he thinks
it's very funny so he joins in with a goofy
bass line and the guitar player joins in too
and Sam Phillips in the control room sticks
his head around the door and says, "What are
you doing?" And the guy said, "I don't know
what we're doing." So he says, "Well, back
it up. See if you can find a place to start
and let's record it." And that is how Elvis
Presley makes his first recording. And so
the fact that Donegan and Elvis should be
so close in time that it should be almost
simultaneous -- almost simultaneous -- says
something about what was happening in your
country and what was happening in my country.
The -- the connection there between guitar
led music -- because I do think that for the
skifflers back in the -- in the 1950s, if
they saw a sign tonight, "skiffle," they wouldn't
necessarily think it would just be Lonnie
Donegan songs. It would be guitar led music,
music played on guitars. It could be blues.
It could be country. It could be calypso.
It could be English folk songs. It could be
anything. It represents the coming of the
guitar for that generation. And what the guitar
represents to them is a break with the past,
a break with the past. The guitar was so unfamiliar
to that generation, Bill Drummond, the genius
behind the KLF, read the book, told me he
first saw a skiffle band when he was six years
old. He thought the guitar player had a hole
in his stomach. Now, you could not get to
six today without seeing someone playing a
guitar. It would be impossible in our culture,
but in British culture in those days, the
guitar represented a break with the -- the
generational curve. It was their way -- those
kids' way of saying, "Old timers, forget it.
This is something new. We're -- we're moving
away from what was before. This is our year
zero." And it's because of the -- the youth
of these people is what is significant. It's
not what they did in '56 and '57 and '58.
It's what they do in '61, '62, '63, '64. You
know? Because what happens is when your young
men, their contemporaries, are learning to
play guitar when they're 16, 17, 18, our teenagers
are already in Hamburg. They're already playing
rock-'n'-roll. And the knock on effect to
that is when the Beatles break into the American
charts in January 1964 and have their first
number one, there's a whole phalanx of British
bands who have been playing seven, eight years
ready to come in behind them. Skiffle is the
nursery for the British Invasion of the American
charts. And between January 1964 and December
1965 there's a British band at number one
in the American charts for 52 weeks out of
104. And every single one of them began as
a skiffle band, the Beatles, the Rolling Stones,
the Tremolos, the Animals, Chad and Jeremy.
The only exception is Petula Clark. Petula
Clark is an exception because, a, she -- when
"Rock Island Line" came out, she had already
released a dozen singles under her own name
and, b, she's a girl. For some reason -- although
there were a number of female performers on
the records -- Nancy Whiskey singing "Freight
Train" you probably heard earlier. And the
City Ramblers, they were Shirley Bland and
Hilda Simms. There are very few photographs
of young women in the records -- of young
women in skiffle bands because that's -- that's
all that's left really because these young
bands, they were so young they didn't make
any records. They are kind of like the soft
parts of a fossil, you can't see them. You
know? It's what they do later you see. So
what's left is literally thousands of photos
like this one, which is a stock photo from
a newspaper archive. Newspaper photographers
loved skiffle bands. And I've seen a lot a
lot of them and the only one I saw that was
an all-women's band was actually some Irish
travelers with their mom who had dressed up
and played skiffle just for the occasion.
So -- but the thing is young women were absolutely
crucial to the whole thing because I think
it was young women's determination to create
their own social space that really made it
possible for the skiffle kids to get out of
the church hall, and the scout [inaudible],
and the school gymnasium and go to somewhere
where there was actually sort of teen interaction
because the young women who suddenly inherited
this incredible spending power, they needed
their own social space. They didn't want to
go in the tea rooms, the Lyons corner house
where they stewed all the food where their
mothers used to take them. They couldn't socially
go into a pub on their own. So they colonized
the brand new cappuccino bars that had started
opening up across the UK in the mid-50s. And
this is very, very significant because the
cappuccino bar offered a level of sophistication
that wasn't there in the rest of the culture.
And by that, I mean they looked towards Paris,
towards Milan, towards Rome, towards Madrid.
You know, this was Jean Seberg rather than
Marilyn Monroe. This was a distinctive determination
to find their own culture. So these women
-- and, you know, they had these beautiful
high-tech gadget machines, these new gadget
machines, and to top it all off, the coffee
bars tended to be covered in this wonderful
new material, Formica.
[ Laughter ]
And the sexual frisson of all that lead inexorably
to the arrival of young men playing guitars
and skiffle. Of course! Where else would you
go? Go where the young women are. I mean you
have a choice. You're a British kid, you have
a choice. You can either go out and play football
with your mates or get a guitar and go down
to the coffee bar where there's girls. It's
-- you know? My sense is that it was young
women that were deriving it. Young women wanted
to jive often when one another. The footage
from the day -- the documentary newsroom footage
from the day often shows young women jiving
with one another. They practiced in their
rooms. My aunties told me that they spent
all their time practicing jiving with one
another only to find that men were useless
at it. Teddy Boys were useless at it so they'd
jive with one another. And there's great footage
of grumpy Teds all standing round while young
women jived to trad jazz. I mean it's -- I
think -- I wish there'd been more time for
me in the book to follow that idea because
I think there's a whole story there of the
-- how young women drove teenage culture during
that period. But the -- I think the crux of
the matter with regard to that generation
of teenagers is that they used American roots
music for a very specific purpose. When the
folk revival became visible in the United
States of America in 1959 when the Kingston
Trio, originally a calypso band into Kingston,
Jamaica -- not Kingston upon Thames, a suburb
of Surrey -- when the Kingston Trio had a
hit with Tom Dooley, the folk revival became
visible culturally here in the United States
of America. And bands like the New Lost City
Ramblers, who were contemporaries of Donegan
and Colyer, they went back to Appalachia to
discover the likes of Doc Watson and Roscoe
Holcomb. They were -- they were escaping from
contemporary American culture back to something
that they felt was more true and pure. The
skiffle kids were doing the absolute opposite.
They were using -- paradoxically using American
roots music to make the future happen, to
escape a past in which they were wearing hand-me-downs,
where their culture was mediated by bureaucrats,
in which their freedom was circumscribed by
parents who -- whose experience in the war
had led them to lower their expectations somewhat.
And Donegan, he breaks the fourth wall of
British pop culture and he says to these kids,
"Take this guitar and build the future with
it." And they built a bridge to the future
so strong that it crossed the Atlantic and
went to the top of the American charts. And
I would argue that we are still living with
the ramifications of what happened in the
skiffle boom. Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
Now we -- we have time for some Q and A. I'm
happy to take questions about anything so
please --
>> Thanks very much.
>> Billy Bragg: My pleasure.
>> I also appreciate the music that you do
and I was wondering, you did some beautiful
work on Mermaid Avenue with all those Woody
Guthrie lyrics and I'm thinking of Walt Whitman
and --
>> Billy Bragg: Ingrid Bergman.
>> Yes.
>> Billy Bragg: Yep.
>> And Ingrid Bergman. How did you piece together
those lyrics? How did you get those lyrics?
And how did you get those beautiful melodies?
>> Billy Bragg: Well, you got to understand
the material that we were working with was
so rich and so sturdy that you -- you know,
you could throw anything at them. "Way Over
Yonder" in the Minor Key you may be familiar
with from the album. I've played that like
a rockabilly song. It still works. The lyrics
are so -- are so good, you can do -- you can
do anything with them. In fact, we did. One
of the great things about Mermaid Avenue,
working with Wilco is every day it was like
going to the dressing up box. "Who are we
going to be today?" You know? "Let's be Tom
Waste today and play all the songs like Tom
Waste. Let's be The Band. Let's be, you know,
"Times They Are A Changin'" Bob Dylan." One
day Wilco decided to be Cheap Trick.
[ Laughter ]
We didn't get much done that day, but --
You know? So really -- I mean, it was -- I
don't know. There was one -- there was one
song called "Go Down to the Water," which
I knew Nora loved. It was about her mother
and her elder sister, Kathy, who sadly died
as a child in a fire. And Woody's writing
to them and their standing on the beach at
Coney Island where Woody and Marjorie's ashes
are scattered. And he's talking about them
going down to the water and watching the convoy
that he's part of depart to D-Day. It's a
very, very powerful song and I knew it was
very important to Nora. And I couldn't get
a handle on it. I couldn't get something on
it that did it justice. And I'd written 20
lyrics by -- 20 of the songs, but I was stuck
with this "Go Down to the Water." I was watching
the TV at home and there was an advert for
Irish Bah. And the soundtrack was Shane MacGowan
from The Pogues singing "She Moves Through
the Fair." And I jumped up from the telly,
ran into the office, pulled out our Lyric,
and sang it to the tune of "She Moves Through
the Fair." And I came back and sat down on
the sofa next to my missus and I says, "21."
[ Laughter ]
So I don't know where it come from, mate.
I really don't know. But all I can tell you
is the material we were working with is so
great we were basically -- I'm sure Jeff and
the guys feel the same -- we were merely providing
the frame for those -- for those works of
art so that it could be hung up on the wall
and everyone could admire them. There seems
to be a gentleman at the front.
>> Hi. Thanks. Are there any scenes out there
these days that interest you or excite you
that make you think it could be where the
next wave of potentially important music could
come from?
>> Billy Bragg: Yeah. Are you familiar with
grime music at all? It's a kind of -- it's
urban music from the UK. It's a mixture of
hip-hop and Jamaica dance hall. And during
the recent general election, the grime artists,
as a genre, came out in support of Jeremy
Corbyn, the leader of the labor party. I haven't
seen that happen since we've been doing red
wedge back in the day. And even then we kept
him at arm's length. But the grime guys, they
didn't. They really went for it. And I think,
one, I'm really pleased about that. Two, I
think they're using music in the way it was
used predominately in the 20th century as
a way of communicating with people who won't
listen to them because they talk to their
own community that way, but it's also their
only opportunity to get in your timeline and
my timeline. Mainstream pop doesn't do that
anymore. Mainstream pop has other ways of
getting in your face. Young people now -- I'm
sorry. Young people have other ways of getting
in your face that don't need to do what I
did when I was 19, which is if I wanted my
voice heard, I had to learn to play guitar,
do gigs, and write songs. But the grime guys
are still doing that. And it kind of -- it's
the answer to the question about where is
all the political music these days? It's right
in front of your face. If your problem is
you're looking -- not you personally. Don't
take this personal. I'm generalizing. I'm
sorry.
[ Laughter ]
I just realized -- I'm sorry. If your problem
is that you want political music and you're
looking for white boys with guitars, Ed Sheeran
is over there, mate. OK? Sorry. It's just
-- I'll get asked -- not this particular question,
but people often say to me, "Where's all the
political music?" I'm like, "just Google,
'grime 4 -- the number 4 -- Corbyn.'" Those
guys are right on it. They are right on it!
Just like punk. Just like skiffle. You know?
Making their own culture for their community
and doing something authentic. It really -- it
really cheered me up. I'm sure there's an
equivalent in the United States of America,
I just don't know about it. Want a secondary,
mate?
>> Yeah. As this gentleman just asked, why
isn't there more of a connection, though,
between political music around the world in
your view?
>> Billy Bragg: Now -- you mean as compared
to the 20th century? Music's lost its vanguard
role in culture. It's as simple as that really.
You know, there's so many different ways.
If you're pissed off about the world, not
there are so many different ways you can articulate
that. You know, you can sort of stir up a
Twitter storm, start a Facebook page, write
a blog. You can make a bloody movie on one
of these things and edit it. I mean, you know,
why go to all the trouble to learn an instrument
and have to stand up in front of people, which
is quite a high bar, you know? It allows -- the
internet and the social media allow more people
to participate in the -- in the 20th century,
there was really only one social medium and
that was music and it had to encapsulate everything,
every experience, love, politics, football,
whatever. You know? And we had, you know,
in my country, four weekly music papers in
which to fresh out the ups and downs of that
and communicate with one another along those
lines. That's not happening in music anymore
apart from in places like grime. And I was
going to say, I'm sure there's scenes in the
US that are like that. But I'm encouraged
that more people are able to, you know -- through
social media, more people are able to contribute
to the -- to the discussion. But no one is
ever going to ask you to tour America reading
out your tweets.
[ Laughter ]
So there's a catch. Sir?
>> So I'm just curious. You're a little younger
than these skiffle musicians and stuff. Can
you draw a line from this to you or how you
were drawn to this subject?
>> Billy Bragg: Yeah, of course. I was born
in peak skiffle, 1957. Peak skiffle is actually
the 6th of July, 1957. We just passed the
60th anniversary of peak skiffle.
[ Laughter ]
That's the day in which John Lennon's band,
The Quarrymen, are playing at Woolton Church
Fete and Paul McCartney turns up to come along
and join the band. Just an interesting aside
-- I will come back to your question -- an
interesting aside, at the height of Beatlemania
here in the United States of America, a DJ
from Philadelphia went to Hamburg to find
out about the Beatles' experiences there and
he met a German wrestler who had been given
the job of looking after the Beatles and keeping
them out of trouble. And he said to this wrestler,
"What were they like when they first came
to Hamburg?" And the guy says, "[in German
accent] Ah! They played too much of that washboard
music."
[ Laughter ]
He said [laughing] -- he said, "[in German
accent] British bands, they think Lonnie Donegan
is Elvis!" And the implications of that -- apart
from the fact I don't do a very good German
accent [laughter] -- the implication of that
is that the Beatles were still a skiffle band
when they got to Hamburg. You know? They were
still basically the three guitar players from
the Quarrymen. So, you know, it's -- it's
not something that just ends in 1958. It ends
in 1977 when the first generation of British
musicians appears that were -- never played
skiffle. Right up to there and there are still
artists -- you know, Ian Hunter from Mott
the Hoople and those kind of guys -- they're
still emerging all the way up to '77. But
it's my generation, the punk rockers, who
are really the first cohort to not have roots
in skiffle. But, incidental -- interestingly,
rather -- skiffle is -- has many similarities
with punk rock, the most obvious one being
the punk rock slogan, "here's three chords,
now form a band." You know? That's exactly
the same as with skiffle. You know, there
were -- there were -- you know, some of the
skiffle bands made Flexi Discs in the way
that punk bands did. There were skiffle fanzines
that people wrote themselves and sold at gigs.
There are many similarities. And if you want
talk about DIY music, well, these guys were
making their instruments with stuff they bought
in a hardware store. How DIY do you want it
to get? You know, I mean? So -- but really
I think the most powerful connection for me
we skiffle is that punk was a music that kind
of empowered you to make your own music. You
know? That was the thing about skiffle. You
don't wait for someone to say, "You can make
music." You just go and do it and skiffle
-- you know, that is the essence of skiffle.
And I think being able to see that period
through the prism of my own experience in
skiffle allowed me to not only understand
better how the scene might develop, but also
to communicate it to a generation younger
than myself who have no reference points in
the early '50s. So there's quite a few references
to punk rock in the book as a way of trying
to marry them up because I think skiffle should
have the same credibility as punk. It doesn't.
It doesn't have very much credibility at all
and the reason for that is that in 1967, pop
turns into rock. Sgt. Pepper's Lonely Hearts
Club Band is released, Rolling Stone magazine
appears, beards are grown [laughter], and
stroked [laughter]. And if you're a -- if
you're a British rock star -- let's say you're
Jimmy Page and Rolling Stone asks, "Who first
inspired you to play guitar?" You're not go
to say Chas McDevitt and Nancy Whiskey are
you? You're going to say Chuck Berry, Elvis
Presley, Buddy Holly. Yet, if you look on
YouTube, there's a fabulous clip of a 14-year-old
Jimmy Page on a BBC TV program playing a song
called "Momma Don't Allow No Skiffle Playing
Around Here." And when he's interviewed by
the avuncular BBC presenter who asks him if
he wants to be a skiffle guitarist when he
grows up, he says, "No," he wants to find
a cure for cancer. But, hey, you can't say
he didn't have ambition, can you?
[ Laughter ]
So that's the -- it's that -- I think what
happens is when rock becomes serious, skiffle
becomes the embarrassing photo in the school
yearbook and gets -- and gets put in the attic.
Some people remember. Some people never forget
the debt they own Donegan, Van Morrison being
one of them, that recorded with Donegan. And
every now and then you get a hint of what
happened. George Harrison was asked if the
Beatles were influenced by the blues and he
said, "Yeah, of course we were. No Lead Belly,
no Lonnie Donegan. No Lonnie Donegan, no Beatles."
And, yet, that quote often appears -- and
he says, "Therefore, no Lead Belly, no Beatles,"
and that quote usually appears as, "No Lead
Belly, no Beatles." Donegan is written out
partly by journalists who were there at the
time who were very sniffy about skiffle. And,
interestingly, the only sniffy response I've
got to the book was from a guy who was there
at the time. And, you know -- and it's something
that that time struggles still to overcome.
You know? Because -- it's understandable.
Rock-'n'-roll is so exciting and it is so
all encompassing. But it was skiffle -- it
was Donegan who put the hands -- put a guitar
in the hands of the war babies, not Elvis
Presley.
>> I just wonder whether there was a reaction,
you know, like there was to punk, a sort of
outrage in newspapers. And you mentioned Teddy
Boys briefly and I know there was sort of
a newspaper outrage about Teddy Boys. So is
that also linked with an older generation
worried about these new kids and what they
were getting up to with their guitars?
>> Yeah. Teddy Boys sort of predates skiffle.
Teddy Boys are kind of there in 1952. There's
a chapter in the book that sort of follows
that as the sort of first British youth cult.
The trouble comes from Rock Around the Clock.
There's a -- the movie, Blackboard Jungle,
which is a pretty good movie, it's Glen Ford,
he's a teacher in a school in I think it probably
must have been in New York somewhere and he's
got a load of hoodlums and he's trying to
educate them. But the movie opens with Rock
Around the Clock and that's the first time
it had been heard in the UK. And if you've
grown up your whole life listening to music
through a speaker about that big and you go
to a cinema and the speakers are as big as
the book there -- cover -- and they're playing
this music loud, you know, people were dancing
in the aisles. People were jumping up and
dancing in the aisles. And a year later a
movie called Rock Around the Clock came out,
which had something like 12 performances by
Bill Haley and his comments in it. I mean,
there were riots. My uncle Dave and my aunt
Christine were at a riot in Rumford. I only
found this out subsequently when I asked them.
And my uncle Dave helped to turn the firehose
on the manager at a cinema.
[ Laughter ]
So there was some concern [laughing] about
it, but also -- also it was -- they attempted
to cooped skiffle as well. It's often -- the
one book that was written by -- about skiffle
in the '50s, written by a vicar.
[ Laughter ]
So, yeah, it was a bit of both. Yes?
>> Hello, Bill.
>> Billy Bragg: Hi [inaudible]. Here I am.
>> How are you?
>> Billy Bragg: Good.
>> Great. No pom poms today.
>> Billy Bragg: OK.
>> But anyway.
>> Billy Bragg: Ken, is it you under that
hat?
>> Yeah, it is.
>> Billy Bragg: Oh, here you are. Sorry, I
didn't see you under the brim. How are you,
mate?
>> Yeah.
>> Billy Bragg: Tell me you bought a new T-shirt.
>> Yeah. Anyway. Great to see you.
>> Billy Bragg: Great to be here.
>> Been a few years. And, of course, I have
to ask about this. As a Jewish guy who is
sitting in Silver Springs, Maryland and who
loves England folk and folk rock and has for
almost 40 years, I'm wondering about the connection
between skiffle and that particular scene.
I seem to recall reading somewhere that Mr.
Martin Carthy was in a skiffle band a long,
long time ago and it does seem to me that
you may be right that the skiffle thing, man,
probably started the English rock-'n'-roll
business over here, the folk rock, and maybe
other stuff.
>> Billy Bragg: It's true, Ken, because what
happens is when rock-'n'-roll comes in, there's
a kind of split between the guys who want
to play beat music, you know, the Beatles
and their cohort. There's another group who
want to play the blues and they become the
Rolling Stones and the Yardbirds. But there's
also a group who are wanting to stay faithful
to playing your acoustic guitar and they kind
of form the very first folk clubs. Ewan MacColl
plays a big role in that. And -- but there
are also significantly a number of Americans
involved in skiffle by pure coincidence. It
just so happens that when "Rock Island Line"
comes in the charts, Alan Lomax is living
in London. He's in London ostensibly to record
a world music series for CBS, but he's also
there because he's afraid he's going to lose
his passport and his job as part of the Red
Scare. So he's there in London. Jack Elliott,
Ramblin' Jack Elliott is also in London when
"Rock Island Line" hits the charts. He's hitchhiking
around the world with his new wife, June Hammerstein,
and he's like -- talk to the skifflers -- he's
like a walking god. I mean, Ron Gold said
to me, "I couldn't believe it the first time
I saw Jack Elliott. He was wearing Levis and
a hat." So, yeah, he was a big figure. And
Peggy Seeger is also in London at the time.
She was traveling around the world and she
started going and playing in the coffee shops
as well. And she played a lot of -- because
her -- very interestingly, her repertoire
had both -- because of the nature of where
she got her repertoire from, some of it was
from the British Isles anyway. You know? It
kind of was from over in the UK. So she fit
right in with the idea of playing folk music,
Ken. You know, she had the -- that beautiful
banjo of hers to play.
>> You know [inaudible] that and she even
reminds me a little bit of [inaudible].
>> Billy Bragg: Yeah.
>> So I'm wondering who --
>> Well, Shirley was in a skiffle band with
Peggy Seeger and Ewan MacColl and Alan Lomax
call the Ramblers. They had a little TV program
and they were kind of using -- MacColl and
Lomax were older, but they were kind of using
music to -- the skiffle music, to get their
agenda, the music they wanted, work songs
and folk songs, onto the radio.
>> Hi. Would you talk a little bit about the
musicology in the book? It looks like there's
a track that -- there were tracks that you
were asking to be played. Is there music accompanying
the book?
>> Billy Bragg: Well, obviously there is,
but it's not in the book I'm afraid. But you
can always -- all this skiffle stuff is on
Spotify now because it's out of -- it's all
out of copyright. So if you can use the titles
in the book -- I thought about putting in
a discography, but I didn't want to narrow
it down. So if you use the titles in the book,
Donegan's easy to find and the rest of the
stuff is easy to find as well.
>> Have you thought about recording some skiffle
yourself at this point? You've got this huge
connection to the music, you're talking about
how it's not really out there, it's this sort
of step child and sort of ignored in history.
Have you thought maybe, not only with the
book that you're clearly very knowledgeable
about and it looks amazing, but maybe putting
out a record of your own with skiffle music?
>> Billy Bragg: Well, interesting, last year
me and a guy name Joe Henry got on a train
in Chicago, Illinois, and rode it all the
way to Los Angeles via San Antonio and when
the train stopped in the largest cities to
allow freight traffic to pass, we jumped off
and recorded a classic railroad song in the
railroad stations along the way. And there
are, when you look at the track listing, I
think there are five Lead Belly songs on the
record including "Rock Island Line". But if
you look at it from the United Kingdom, there's
five Lonnie Donegan songs on it.
[ Laughter ]
So it's kind of -- that kind of is our record.
Can I say something about cultural appropriation
because that's been a question that has come
up a few times if you're interested? In 1956,
Lonnie Donegan had a hit with the song called
"Stewball," which is a quite famous folk song,
concerns a jockey whose racehorse speaks to
him and tells him how he's going to win the
race. Lead Belly recorded it. Woody recorded
it. Now, Lead Belly could have got it from
two places. He could have got it from his
own experience because it was a song very
familiar to African American field workers.
So familiar it was the Lomax's who recorded
a version that Lead Belly may have heard,
they said it was the most common song they
found when they were recorded in the 1930s
among African American sharecroppers. Now,
100 years before that, "Stewball" was being
sung in boarding houses and bars in New York
and Boston. A hundred years before that, it
was being sold as a broadside ballad on the
streets of George in London. And in 1752-3,
the actual event on which the song was based
happened at the Curragh of Kildare in Ireland.
Now, given that progress, who does this song
belong to? Who has the rights to say, "This
is my song?" Lead Belly? Lomax? Woody? I mean,
at least Donegan had an Irish money. He did
have a [inaudible] I think in the holy [inaudible].
But I think that one of the problems with
the debate about appropriation is it runs
contrary really to the spirit of music. Music
belongs to everyone or no one. You know? It
kind of lives by being sung. Martin Carthy
who Ken just mentioned had a great phrase.
Once he said to me, "The only bad thing you
can do to a song is not sing it." You can't
put it in a corner and say, "This belongs
here." MacColl tried this. MacColl and Peggy
tried this in the folk clubs in London in
the '60s and said you can only sing songs
that come from your own culture. And it was
like a, you know, like a form of Stalinism.
You know, who needs -- folk music doesn't
need police. You know? It needs -- it needs
to go wherever it goes because the great thing
about "Rock Island Line" is Lead Belly didn't
write it either! You know, Lead Belly heard
it from Lomax. He and John Lomax working together
recorded it in Cummins Prison Farm in Arkansas
and in 1935. I'm proud to say I held the paper
sleeve of the original recording with John
Lomax's handwriting on today in the other
building. It was a moment of deep meaning
to me I have to say. But, you know, the guys
who sang in the prison, Kelly Pace and the
other seven prisoners who came to Lomax's
microphone and sang "Rock Island Line" as
a call and response song, they didn't write
it. They didn't write it either. It was originally
appeared Rock Island employees working in
Little Rock in the engine sheds in Little
Rock. The company encouraged the formation
of glee clubs and, in this case, it was an
African American quartet who wrote this song
and would perform it at social functions to
advertise the railroad. That's where it really
starts. And who knows that they didn't borrow
a song from somewhere else? And Donegan -- Donegan
also -- everybody who sang that song added
something to it. The great thing that Donegan
does is he introduces the idea of a toll gate
on the record. If you listen closely to Lead
Belly's record, Lead Belly, the signalman
is telling the train driver to go in the hole,
which means in a siding, because in the golden
age of American railroads, freight had to
give way to express trains. But it was an
exemption on animal welfare grants if you
were carrying livestock. So the train driver
says to the signalman, "I've got all livestock.
I've got pigs. I got horses," and he says,
"OK. You can carry on." And then he pulls
away and he shouts back, "I fooled you. I
got pigiron," which may be a pun, maybe a
pun by Lead Belly. In Donegan's version, there's
a toll gate and he's having to pay some kind
of a tariff. Now, there never was a toll gate
on the American railroad ever. Donegan -- Donegan
kind of got -- I don't know what -- maybe
he didn't understand what Lead Belly was saying,
but he invented that. But, interestingly,
he watermarked the song. He watermarked the
song. Anyone you hear singing a version with
a toll gate in it, it's Donegan's version
they've learned rather than Lead Belly's version.
And, interestingly, Johnny Cash's first album
for Sun Records in 1957 starts with "Rock
Island Line" and he mentions a goddam toll
gate.
[ Laughter ]
So we have a saying in the American Folklife
Center which is, "What goes around, comes
around," and that's [laughter] -- that's how
you explain skiffle. It's how you explain
the Beatles. It's how you explain "Stewball."
It's how you explain the multicultural society
that we belong to. The people are able to
hear music from outside their own cultural
context, be inspired by it, and grow up to
love the people who made that music. And that's
-- that's the great thing about folk music.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephen Winick: So we want to thank everyone
for coming and we want to say that there's
a table out in the front where you can buy
books and you can get Billy to sign books
if you've already bought them. So we're going
to be there for just about an hour. We have
to be out of the building at 9:30. So that
is our deadline. So head out the front and
you'll see Billy there. Thanks very much once
again on the behalf of the American Folklife
Center and the Library of Congress.
>> This has been a presentation of the Library
of Congress. Visit us at loc.gov.